le premier à des qualités il a une
première qualité c'est qu'il permet de
respecter l'équilibre financier le
retour à l'équilibre financier en 2030
il y a une deuxième qualité qui est que
ce texte reprend et comporte évidemment
tout est dispositions qui font le cœur
de la réforme que le gouvernement a
présenté devant le Parlement et enfin
une troisième qualité c'est que ce texte
a été amélioré amélioré par le débat
parlementaire avec une mesure favorable
aux femmes qui ont une carrière complète
avec une meilleure prise en compte de la
pénibilité des carrières longues avec de
nombreux amendements issus de la
majorité comme des oppositions qui
permettent de renforcer les droits de
faciliter la vie des assurés et d'aller
vers un système de retraite qui soit à
la fois équilibré c'est notre objectif
premier et amélioré est-ce qu'on peut
dire que maintenant il reste plus dur
monsieur du stop et il reste un débat à
l'Assemblée nationale et l'assemblée
doit se prononcer sur les conclusions de
la commission mixte paritaire c'est un
moment qui est important nous avons tout
au long du débat veiller à ce que
l'ensemble de celles et ceux qui
s'inscrivaient dans une perspective
constructive c'est à dire une
perspective qui consiste à partager
l'objectif de la réforme ça nécessite
face qui est marqué parce que les deux
mondes puissent être entendues des
demandes qui sont entendues c'est à la
fois garantir l'équilibre c'est un une
préoccupation partagée par la majorité
présidentielle et par la majorité
sénatoriale et par le groupe des
Républicains à l'Assemblée nationale
faire en sorte de répondre aux demandes
c'est faire attention c'est ce que nous
avons fait ce que le texte permet parce
que la revalorisation des plus petits
conscience s'applique au retraités
actuel et pas seulement au nouveau
retraité parce que les carrières longues
soient améliorées nous l'avons fait et
la commission mixte paritaire là encore
améliorée est-ce que vous avez une
majorité confiance du matin
si députés qui sont
comment dire intéressés qui sont
concernés et qui souhaitent le retour à
l'équilibre financier si tous les
députés qui souhaitent que ce système
soit amélioré que la question de la
pénibilité des carrières longues des
petites pensions soit des situations qui
soient revalorisées si tous les députés
qui sont d'accord avec cette réforme qui
est attendez qu'il a demandé qu'il
apporte et qui sont convaincus que le
retour à l'équilibre et l'amélioration
du système sont au rendez-vous votes il
y a une majorité il faut que cette
majorité se forme et avec le président
de la République avec la première
ministre avec les membres du
gouvernement nous continuons à dire à
défendre et à souligner que celles et
ceux qui sont attachés au système de
répartition c'est pas répartition au
stream de solidarité
intergénérationnelle et à son
amélioration doivent se retrouver cet
après-midi et si votre taux s'il y a une
majorité à la semaine prochaine à 10h45
ce matin nous sommes déterminés à
construire cette majorité et à faire
entendre faire voir et montrer que si
les parlementaires qui souhaitent
l'équilibre du système et son
amélioration vote il y a une majorité
c'est notre chantier notre engagement
des prochaines
[Musique]